The first thing that I notice when I look at this, and really the first thing
that you should check for whenever you look at any polynomial expression, is
that there's a common factor of 2, in every term in the expression. So let's
start by pulling that out. Now we only need to concern ourselves with what's
inside these parenthesis, just have to make sure that we don't lose track of
this 2. Now it's time to factor by grouping. You can pull out 2x squared, out of
these first 2 terms, and the last 2 terms are a little bit tricky, because they
only share a factor of, well, 1, so that is what we will write. Luckily, we
still see that we have a common factor, between the two terms we have left. The
fully factored form of this is then, 2 times the quantity x minus 3 times the
quantity of 2x squared plus 1. Now in the event that you forgot to pull out the
common factor of 2 at the very beginning, all is not lost, we can still solve
the problem that way too, let's check it out. If we start off by grouping,
instead of pulling the common factor of 2, then we can just proceed by factoring
by grouping as normal. We end up with x minus 3, times 4x squared plus 2. At
this point, however, when we think that we're fully factored. We have to take
that last step to double check, and make sure that neither of these factors has
a greatest common factor greater than 1. We see, however, that this term, 4x
squared plus 2, has a common factor of 2 between its terms. Then we pull that
out. And that is what gives us our final factored form, which of course is the
same answer that we got doing the problem the other way. Awesome job.